let's talk about conflict of interest
so you said you could advertise public
you have a popular Twitter account
it's it's hilarious and insightful
uh you do promote Bitcoin
in a sense I don't know if you would say
that but do you think there's a conflict
of interest in anyone who owns Bitcoin
promoting Bitcoin is it the same as you
promoting the farming
I would say no there's an interest I
think that I think that um you can
promote
a property
or an idea
to the extent that uh you don't control
it I think that the point at which you
start to have a conflict of interest is
when you're promoting a proprietary
product or proprietary security a
security and general is proprietary
asset
so for example if you look at my Twitter
you will find that I make lots of
statements about Bitcoin you won't ever
see me making a statement that say
microstrategy stock will go off forever
right I'm not promoting a security mstr
because at the end of the day mstr is a
security it is proprietary I have
proprietary interest in it I have a
disproportionate amount of control and
influence on the direction which solves
the problem the control is the problem
because you have interest in both you
can very if Bitcoin is a successful as
we're talking about you are very
possibly can become the richest human on
earth
given how much you own a Bitcoin right
the wealthiest not the richest I don't
know what those words mean I I would
benefit economically economic you would
benefit economically that's true so the
the reason that's not conflict of
interest is because uh the word property
that Bitcoin is an idea and it's because
I don't control it in essence the the
ethical line here is could I print
myself 10 million more Bitcoin or not
right like why can anyone right it's not
just you it's can anyone
because can you promote somebody else's
yes I guess you can
like if you can you promote uh uh Apple
you could have a Twitter account where
you promote oil or you promote camping
or you promote family values or promote
you know a carnivore diet or promote the
Iron Man right that you're not going to
get wealthier if you promote camping
because you can't own a steak and I mean
you own a lot of Bitcoin what is that
what is that what again don't you own a
steak in the idea
yeah I would I would grant you that
but the lack of control is the
fundamental ethical line that you just
you don't have all you are is you're a
fan of the idea you believe in the idea
and the power of the idea
yeah I think you can't take that idea
away from others let's come back to let
me give you some maybe easier examples
if you were the head of the Marine Corps
right and uh
and someone came to you and said I
created Marine coin and uh and the Twist
on Marine coin is is I want you to tell
every Marine that they'll get an extra
Marine coin you know when they when they
get their next stripe and then I'm gonna
give you you know and I'm gonna let you
buy marine coin now and then after you
buy marine coin I want you to like uh
promote it
to them
right at some point if if you start to
have a disproportional influence on it
or if you're in a conversation with
people with disproportionate influence
becomes conflict of interest and it
would make you profoundly uncomfortable
I think yeah if the head of the Marine
Corps started promoting anything that
looked like a security
now if the head of the Marine Corps
started promoting canoeing
you might think he's kind of wacky like
maybe like that's kind of a waste of
time a distraction so but but
but to the extent that canoeing is not a
security not a problem unless you you
know ultimately the the issue of
decentralization is really a critical
not having a head one so is it something
can can Bitcoin be replicated
so the all the things that you're saying
that make it a property can that be
replicated have any other possible to
create other crypto properties does it
does the having a head like of a project
a thing that limits its ability to be a
property if you if you try to replicate
a project
right is that the fundamental flaw I
look I I think the real fundamental
issue is you just never want it to
change
like like uh if you really want
something decentralized you want a
genetic template that substantially is
not going to change for a thousand years
so I think Satoshi said it at one point
he said the nature of the software is
such that by version 0.1 its genetic
code was set
if if there was any development team
that's continually changing it you know
on a routine basis it becomes harder and
harder to maintain its decentralization
because now now there's the issue of
who's influencing
the changes